The world of direct
ticket issuing and processing
was shaken to its core last week
when Ticketmaster, the most...
That's how I'm gonna say
it from now on. Ticketmaster.
...the most popular
ticket seller in the world
behind Briansetzerstubs.com--
sure you're all familiar.
Uh, they're in the midst
of a class-action lawsuit.
Courts ruled that Ticketmaster
had to pay back consumers
millions and millions of dollars
in bull (bleep) service charges.
Rather than provide
cash refunds, though,
Ticketmaster's offering vouchers
and discount codes
that can only be used for,
quote, "eligible events,"
which is Ticketmaster code
for (bleep) events.
(laughter)
Here's what Twitter user
@Cryptoterra had
to say about it.
(laughter)
(applause and cheering)
Could be worse. Imagine opening
your "free vouchers" tab
and seeing something like
"Walking on the Soleil,"
the "Smash Mouth
Cirque du Soleil" show.
(laughter)
♪ Might as well be walking
on soleil. ♪
Circus (bleep).
-(laughter)
-All right, comedians,
as a Ticketmaster user,
please open your tab
and find out what (bleep)
ticket voucher they gave you.
Dave Hill.
Two tickets to see Nickelback.
Also, you are in Nickelback.
-(laughter)
-HARDWICK: Oh, wow.
-I'm... My voucher puts me
in Nickelback. -Yeah.
(applause and cheering)
Points.
Mary Holland. Mary Holland.
I got front row seats
and backstage passes
to Third Eye Blind,
and I'm not allowed to say no!
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
-(applause and cheering)
-Thank you.
♪ Joe Randazzo's next.
Oh, nice!
Front row seats to Billy Joel's
semi-annual prostate exam.
(laughter)
Right up front.
♪ I'm gonna have
to get a big shot! ♪
-(laughter)
-Yes!
-HOLLAND: I would actually...
-(applause and cheering)
-I would actually like to see
that. -I mean... -It's tough.
-I don't know what, you know?
-(overlapping chatter)
When he gets a prostate exam,
it's called "The Stranger."
-(laughter)
-You get it?
-Points.
One, two, three, four,
pressure.
(laughter)